[Music]
all right so what you're hearing is the
open AI Duke box this paper came out and
it is a surprisingly good quality
generative model for music including
lyrics so including singing which I
believe is pretty novel and the fact
that it works so well and has musical
consistency throughout entire songs is
something that is very very novel and
cool all right so we're looking at the
paper it's called jukebox a generative
model for music and it's by Prafulla
diaval
hey whoa June Christine pine jung-woo
Kim Alec Radford and Ilya sutskever of
open AI so the model here is a is not
very novel but I think the the way they
set it up makes a lot of sense and we'll
quickly go through it and look at what
comes out of this this is not a very
technical paper but I think it's a it's
a it's well written and their main thing
is these vq v IE models so these models
if you know you might know what a
variational auto encoder is so in a
variational auto encoder I have an input
let's say an image here of our typical
cat and I put it through what is called
an encoder in order to get a hidden
representation now this hidden
representation usually called something
like Z or H is then in a in a classic
auto encoder I would here have a decoder
and then I train that decoder to match
that in that original picture as closely
as possible so I train these two neural
networks the encoder and the decoder to
just basically compress to this
representation and then reproduce again
the original image and thereby I think I
can learn
hidden representation now in a
variational auto-encoder what happens is
there is an in-between step namely this
Z representation here is not directly
fed to the decoder but this
representation is actually used to
parameterize gaussians so in the easiest
case we have let's say we have six
dimensions here in the hidden
representation the first two are used to
parameterize the first gaussian one is
going to be the mean and one is going to
be the standard deviation of that
Gaussian and the second two are going to
parameterize the second Gaussian and the
third are going to parameterize the
third one so we have now three gaussians
and then from those three Gaussian
distributions we're going to sample a
three dimensional vector and then we're
going to feed that three dimensional
vector to the decoder so every input
image in essence is giving us a
distribution in the latent space and not
just a single vector it's just is giving
us a vector that describes an entire
multivariate Gaussian distribution and
then we train the decoder basically to
reconstruct the encoder given that
distribution so the variational auto
encoder has improved over the classic
auto encoder because it tends to to
circumvent some of these shortcomings
but still variational auto-encoders have
their problems and in terms of
generative model for images people as
you know have gone to things like ganz
and so on but here this new thing is
called the v QV AE and that's a because
I believe this stands for vector
quantization not entirely sure honestly
but so what it does is it takes the
input right here and again it maps it to
a latent code and these latent code I
believe are our air called H so it Maps
it to a vector called H now
here's where it gets different we do
have a so called codebook here so a
codebook is just a list of vectors this
is the codebook and these are here
called e so what we'll do is we'll
simply look for H which one's the
closest neighbor in the codebook that we
have of hidden vectors and we'll map it
to that and say oh this is this here is
the closest neighbor so we'll basically
quantize the hidden representation to
these codes so we're end up only with
vectors that are these codes and now
instead of saving the vector H first of
all we get a super compressed
representation because if these are like
16 16 code book vectors we can just
simply enumerate them right and then we
can simply encode the image as one or a
sequence of these indices here but
second of all it tends to bring a more
kind of a diversity and accuracy if we
then decode from these these code
vectors now of course everything is
trained here so the encoder is trained
and the code books themselves are also
trained and the decoder is also trained
to give you the maximum kind of benefit
so this is what is described here what
they have is first of all their loss for
these vqv AES and you'll see how they
are using them to generate music in a
second their loss is part this
reconstruction loss which you can see
here this is the original image how far
is it away from the decoded hidden
quantized representation this e here
this is the quantized the codebook
vector that belongs to the hidden
representation of X so this is your
standard reconstruction loss the next
part of the loss is this codebook loss
now the codebook loss is for training
these codebook vectors so it basically
pulls the codebook back
closer to the actual hidden
representation so that is where you
train these this here is a stop gradient
so basically just means that you want
your codebook vectors to be better
representing of the data that you feed
in because otherwise it would be useless
code for collectors and the third part
of their loss is the these commit loss
right here and that is exactly the
opposite now you put to stop gradient on
the codebook vector and you simply want
to pull the hidden representation closer
to the codebook vector such that imagine
the encoder must learn to approximately
hit one of these codebook vectors right
otherwise it can it cannot really learn
something meaningfully it must learn to
deal with the codebook vectors that are
there and to approximately map the input
into the vicinity of one of one of the
codebook vectors otherwise there's no
information flowing so that's how you
train things you train the encoder and
the decoder to reconstruct you train the
codebook vectors to represent the data
and you also train the encoder to make
good use of the codebook vectors
honestly now that I think about it I am
pretty sure in the reconstruction loss
you might only train the decoder because
you do have this quantization step in
between in this in this thing here so
technically you could not back propagate
through that alright so that's how you
train the individual parts of a vqv AE
and we'll see how they use it in order
to produce music alright so what they do
is they start off with a sample of music
and they send it through this thing
through this architecture and at the end
they are trying to reconstruct the same
thing they had at the beginning so you
see this overarching
auto encoder architecture that's why
it's an auto encoder
you try to reconstruct your input and
thereby you try to learn something about
the data because a model that can
compress and then uncompress all of your
data has learned something useful about
it now you have these vqv AES here in
the middle but you have them at
different scales so you'll have three of
those here there is a coarse scale one
middle scale one and a high frequency
one right so three vqv AES right here
and you train each one of them
separately and the difference between
them is that the so because this is a
continuous signal you cannot just encode
a continuous signal because it's an
audio waveform what you have to do is
you have to go through it in some sort
of a a stepwise fashion you have to
divide it into individual pieces and
encode each of those pieces as one
hidden a vector or one element of the
codebook and the size is here the
precise size of how you go through the
audio that is different between the V
these different scales so in this scale
right here you go through the audio in
very small steps right this as you can
imagine gives you the best
reconstruction so this is the audio that
is like this right and you just take
part of it like from here to here and
you encode it into a single hidden
vector which is this brown thing here
then you take the next one the next
slice and you encode it and that'll give
you this blue thing here then you run
this sequence through the vector
quantization step where each of those
will be mapped so you have a codebook
here right yeah your codebook and you
look up the first one and you decide ah
this probably goes here the to disco
director so you put that code vector
into the first place they take the
second place and you might decide now
that's this one so you put this one into
the second place and the third one you
might decide
ah no that also is closest to the first
codebook vector so you again put the
first codebook vector into that slot now
the that doesn't mean that it's the same
music but of course the the decoder now
is going to look at the entire sequence
and can decide our probably isn't the
exact same note as here but it might
decide you know that the the chord
played will repeat or something like
this so there's this vector quantization
step and the codebook look up so yeah
this this minimizes which which the
vector of the codebook is closest and
the codebook lookup I think will just
replace then the decotis this vector
with the actual codebook things and so
there's this slight difference here's of
Z here as you can see is the argument K
so the argument that is the actual
number K which codebook vector is the
closest and then this e ZT will be the
actual vectors so this here is actually
what I described right here but this is
I think a detail and you're gonna do
this at different scales now you can
imagine that the bottom one is going to
give you the best most faithful
reconstruction when you decode it right
but it is also going to learn about the
kind of details in the music the
short-term details
whereas this coarse-grained one it can
learn things about longer range
compositions it might not produce as
correct of a reconstruction but it can
learn long range dependencies such as
the structure of a song or the structure
of a verse or something like this so
these are independent of each other and
um they make an argument as to why so
people have tried to and share these
architectures but have found that mainly
the models will will basically ignore
the top two and on will only go of riah
the coarse-grained ones so that's why
they complete
they separate these at this stage of
training all right so we have trained
three different via is at three
different scales of music to always
reconstruct the input what does that
give us
that gives us a distribution right here
that gives us a way to take a piece of
music and map it to this hidden space to
this very compressed representation in
this quantized world right I've said
before this is a very compressed
representation of your data why can why
can you do that sorry
what's that useful for what you can do
now is you can try to sample from in
that hidden space so instead of sampling
music we have no clue of how to sample
music unless we are given some music
what we can do is we can say maybe this
thing here because it's compressed it
kind of so if we just sample a waveform
it's very unlikely that it's music and
but if we sample these hidden things you
know it's quite likely that if we feed
it through the decoder something will
come out and even better maybe our data
set in this hidden space follows a kind
of a simpler distribution one that we
could learn right so we're trying we're
gonna try to learn a prior distribution
over the distribution of codebook
vectors and that is naturally going to
be a joint distribution between the top
middle and bottom vqv AES and we can
decompose this into the following things
simply by applying the standard
probabilistic transfer algebra
transformation and we can then they say
when trying separate models sorry that
we train separate models for the top
level prior the top the middle and the
bottom so what that means is basically
these are now neural networks if if you
read something like this
a paper like this this is going to be a
neural network that takes the right side
as an input and produces the left side
right so you start out with this one
this is a neural network that simply
takes as an input sorry I'm going to
draw this neural network takes as an
input maybe something like a Gaussian
super prior right you sample from that
and that will as an output give you this
Zita
then the next neural network will take
this as an input and will give you the
middle as an output and then the final
neural network will input the two of
those and give you the top and you can
train these neural networks simply by
kind of training a prior to produce this
thing right here you'd simply use your
data compress it to the hidden space and
then train a neural network to produce
that distribution and you can do this in
any number of ways you can use classic
VA s you can use you can sorry you can
use here they say we use transformers
with sports attention as they're
currently state-of-the-art in Auto
regressive modeling and they say we
propose a simplified version which we
call the scalable transformer that is
easier to implement and scale right but
they see you see they model this
distribution with these scalable
transformers all right so now what do we
have we have a way to sample these
hidden vectors right so we don't need we
don't need this part anymore this part
sorry about this part here was just used
for training we can we now have our
transformers they take nothing as an
input or they they take like a Gaussian
as an important they can
oddly output this hidden representation
so we could technically sample from that
and then just push it through this
decoder of the vqe but the question is
which of the three do we take and
wouldn't it be great if we can combine
them because if we simply sample these
this higher scale one we just get not
very long range dependencies right
because that's what the vqe I learned if
we just sample this one then we just get
a coarse music and we can sample all
three but they will just give us three
different tracks of music so we want to
combine the three decoders into one
somehow and that's we do this through
these up samplers so what we'll use what
we'll target actually is this bottom one
we target this one because this one
gives us the best quality music right
because it was trained with the shortest
time scale we're going to try to in to
take the other signals and and influence
it so we'll start with the top level
prior right that will produce us these
transformers will per give us a sequence
a sequence of tokens in the hidden space
that is very coarse as you can see here
and then we'll feed that into a up
sampler in these up samplers again are
under neural networks that can connect
the different scales through with each
other right so you can connect this to
this it's basically like conditioning
the model that produces the sequence on
this sequence right here and again we
use an up sampler to up sample this to
the finest scale and that we feed in the
bottom scale and then we get our music
now throughout all of this that you have
conditioning information here which is a
bit of an addition to the model so the
conditioning information can be things
like artists genre
and timing and this is seem appears to
be pretty important because you kind of
first of all want some variety and then
second of all use sort of want to
control what music is produced and you
don't just want to train a this model
for us one single artist because you
have much more data across all of music
so this conditioning information is just
included here via another neural network
and you can find all the architectures
for all of these models in the paper
it's not particularly important I
believe how exactly you include them but
the fact that you do the last thing is
what they do is they do this kind of
windowed sampling so in order to produce
music you're gonna have to produce these
um these slices of music right here but
you sort of have a maximum length here
that your models can handle and this is
usually not the length of a song you may
know transformers and so on they have
usually have token limits of like 512
tokens in terms of audio that's not that
much so what you do is this window
sampling where you sample something and
then you condition basically on the
first part and then you just sample the
next thing and then you again condition
on the first part and then you just
sample the next thing the next few ones
and that guarantees that each of the
sampling steps is basically conditioned
on what comes before as you see up here
so you would always sort of condition on
a part produce the next part all right
and they say you can also basically
condition on so you can feed in you
don't have to sample the very first one
you can also feed in an existing song in
order to prime the system so what you
can do is if you have a beginning of a
song then you can let
the system finished the song by simply
taking the song running it through the
encoder that we produce during training
right you get these hidden
representations so you don't actually
have to sample them from their prior and
then you run this generation process as
if this came out of your prior instead
of what you sampled okay so let's have a
look at how that sounds our a listen
this this is an explorer they release
many many samples from this and the part
here where we're going to listen is
called no lyrics conditioning
[Music]
so
as you can hear this is already pretty
good music and the genre is American
folk the singer is Peter Seeger a CEREC
Pete Seeger this already sounds very
authentic but you can hear that the
lyrics are just kind of mumbly right and
that's because the model is basically
asked to come up with lyrics from as
pure audio waveforms and that results in
some subpar lyrics basically it just
produces phonemes that sound like the
singer it doesn't produce entire words
and of course it also doesn't produce
sentences that make any sort of sense
and that's why they're building in an
additional thing to do
lyrics conditioning so with lyrics
conditioning the idea is that in the
conditioning information you also add
lyrics so here is plus text so you add
text and then the model is basically can
also look at the text now you never you
still you still so even before we had
music with lyrics and the decoder was
always asked to reconstruct that and so
none of that changes that's why it has
learned to produce phonemes right
but now the decoder can also and also
the encoder did the system can look at
the lyrics that you provide right here
in order to help with its decoding so
technically it could learn to bypass the
encoding of the exact way the lyrics are
uttered and it could just look at the
text that you provide now this of course
requires that during training you
provide the lyrics of the song that are
actually that that you feed in but also
it means that during decoding if you
sample you can then provide your own
lyrics and look what happens so
they say they provide lyrics they always
have to pride lyrics for chunks of
audios or our data set includes song
level lyrics but to make it easier we
train on shorter 24 second chunks of
audio and this is partly to make it
easier for the model but also partly
because those appear to be the
limitations of these systems right if
you have transformers in there and
whatnot 24 seconds of raw audio waveform
is lot so they have this problem of if
this problem of they have a song from
here to here and they have the lyrics
blah blah blah and they need to know
which lyrics belong to which part of the
song and usually it's it's it's
monotonic right in linear because you
get the lyrics from some lyrics website
this blah blah but you don't know
particularly to which 24 second chunk
they belong so they say first of all
they started with simply linearly
aligning the lyrics but then they had
some they they had some problems with
fast songs so they had some heuristic
here but ultimately the the decoder
needs to learn to attend to these lyrics
and these the graphics like this you see
here is the music tell composition and
lyrics to composition so here you see
the the system learns that for example
if it has it this music token it needs
to attend to this token in the lyric so
you can by inspecting these attention
heads that you have on the lyrics texts
in the system you can see which lyrics
the model is paying attention to and the
fact that it learns to pay linearly
attention to these things is kind of a
confirmation because you you don't you
give the whole text or at least the 24
second chunks of audio you give that at
once as a as a text right and the fact
that it learns to linearly attend to the
tokens is a confirmation that it
actually includes that information in 2d
coding and
that is pretty gives you pretty much
better results so we can maybe go to
classic pop
[Music]
so this our unseen lyrics so the model
has never seen these lyrics right it was
just asked to produce classic pop in the
style of Frank Sinatra with these lyrics
and that's what it came up with that is
pretty pretty pretty cool I think they
also have rear end Asians where they
basically feed I believe feed in the
original lyrics we conditioned on lyrics
scene during training and they have fun
songs and in the fun songs I like the
hip hop in G style of Kanye West where
they provide the lyrics of Eminem's lose
yourself
yeah these palms were sweaty knees weak
palms are heavy there's vomit on his
sweater already mom's getting nervous
but on the surface too much for me I'm
grooving I don't know what you're
thinking but this is cool and they can
also as we said to do these completions
where they start with part of a song and
just I have to do this I have to do this
video copy strike because what you would
hear would be the original never going
to give you up like ten seconds of it
and then followed by what the model
continues with so as a substitute you're
now going to have to listen to me
I hope that suffices
[Music]
you know
almost as good almost as good as the
original
so as you can see this the results here
are pretty pretty cool and I want to
show you one last thing and that is this
Christmas song in the style of Frank
Sinatra I believe it's this one right
here and the special thing here is it's
again classic pop in the style of Frank
Sinatra and you see on the bottom here
you see on the bottom which of the
lyrics it's attending to and you see you
know this this graph right here that
shows you that first it's attending
linearly through the lyrics but then it
kind of jumps around and attends to
different things because it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't just continue so
[Music]
some leather the leather makes Breanna
see where this is great so it kind of
falls out of this linearly attending to
the lyrics and probably because there
was sort of a pause in the lyrics and
maybe this is just more than one audio
window so it doesn't have this
autoregressive property anymore and then
it doesn't find the proper place to
attend anymore and so just again comes
up with sort of babbles but it sounds
pretty pretty cool yeah so this they
have released many many samples here
some cherry picked and just a lot of
samples with unseen lyrics rerun ditions
and so on this all is very cool they
have their training set up described I
believe they also release their code
many more results in the paper of how to
make this thing work if you want to do
that yourself and with that I invite you
to read the paper if you're still here
please subscribe if you like this
content
leave a comment and bye bye
[Music]
let you down